A newcomer's observation: It's
like an early impression of a Chinese woman on the outside.She's
proud of her qualifications, shares her family background, and is
different from the high-class inns.That's
why she goes out of her way to work.  No, there's no need to clean.
What are you thinking? The better the food, the
better the growth. I'm
asking you why a child like you is under the
direct control of Hitoshi-sama.
Even if you stay silent, you're just playing on the other person's nerves.
In other words,
you're all jealous of me.
Don't worry, I said the wrong word. I ca
n't help it. I'm being treated special. There's no way that's the
case.
So, are you such a bad eater as you think?
Would you go out of your way to eat chicken bones with the meat scraped off when you have abalone and meat right in front of you?  Well then, how
maniacal is that? I don't
know, but is it some kind of special hobby? Well, it's
not that special. If so, then why are you being
hired for
[music]?
[Music]
The other day, I experimented with burn medicine, so I'm
a bit sore. I
know that you, the one who is like me, are heaven to your heart. He
also feeds people like me.
So let's go.
[Music]
It's over, it's over, maniac. Are you
always involved in things like that?
Or rather, what are you going to do with your left hand up? Now, let's move on to the next task of cleaning. I
wonder if you're studying?
Hey
JA